hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to explain to you step by step
why multiplying numbers by drawing lines
actually works we're going to explain in
detail why this somewhat magical diagram
of 12 by 13 equals 156 what this
actually represents and why this
actually works we'll start out with some
simple examples let's say you wanted to
do 2 times 1 so we'll draw two lines and
in the other direction we have one line
we count the dots and we get two dots
and two times one is two if we wanted to
do two times two we'll put one more line
and we'll get four dots continuing the
pattern when we have two times three we
draw one more line and that gives us six
the point of this is that each time we
have another number
every new line leads to two more dots
and this is exactly the process of
multiplying by two so if we wanted to
multiply any number by two we could have
we could put place that many number of
lines in the other direction and count
up the number of dots will illustrate
this with two times thirteen we'll have
two lines for the two and now we'll
place thirteen lines in the other
direction if you count these dots there
will be twenty six dots and two times 13
is 26 this example demonstrates that
when you multiply by lines it will
become cumbersome to keep using a lot
you know one line for each number so if
we have 13 the number 13 it already
looks messy that we have 13 different
lines or 13 sticks for the number 13
so we're going to need a way to do this
faster and that's pretty much what
multiplying by lines is so the trick
we're going to use is we're going to
group ten of these lines or ten of these
sticks into a bundle you could imagine
if you have ten different sticks you put
them in a bundle and wrap them with the
wire or string so we're going to take
ten of these lines and we'll group them
as one line so this one big green line
this thick green line really represents
ten of the lines from the number
thirteen now we're going to count the
dots for these small dots we already
have six points six dots and now we need
to count these two intersections these
two dots because that big green line
represents ten different lines each
intersection is 10 so this is 10 dots
here this is really like 10 dots and
this is really 10 dots here so 10 plus
10 is 20 and when we add that to the six
we have 26 so we can do 2 times 13
instead of having 13 different lines we
can have one line for the one a big line
representing 10 of the of the lines and
we'll have three of the regular lines so
I hope you understand how this example
works because now we're going to go to a
more advanced method and we're going to
imagine doing 12 by 13 so what we could
do for 12 is in addition to the two
lines we already have we could add 10
more lines and if we go through and
count all the dots we will get the
answer but just as before we're going to
group these ten lines into a single
bundle and we're going to make it one
thick line and this thick line is really
ten
so when we count the intersections we're
going to have to remember it's ten lines
now we'll start counting the number of
dots as before we have six dots here on
the right we've created three
intersections between a thin line and
the ten line which gives us ten each
time so in the middle we have ten plus
ten plus on the bottom ten plus ten
which makes for 50 finally we have the
intersection of two ten lines so if you
were to draw out ten different lines and
then draw another ten different lines
the number you're going to get out the
number of dots will be ten times ten and
ten times ten is a hundred so the
intersection of two ten lines is 100 now
we simply add up all the different
numbers because the whole point of
multiplication by lines is to count up
the number of dots so on the Left we
have a hundred dots in the middle we
have fifty dots and on the right we have
six so 100 plus 50 plus six is 156 and
that's the essence of multiplying by
lines but when you do this operation
over and over again you don't need to
draw out all the different details we
put in this diagram we can in fact leave
out some of the details just because we
do this over and over again we'll
understand what the different lines mean
so the first thing we can do is we can
remove the labels on the ten we will
just keep in mind that the intersection
of a thick line and a thin line is ten
the next thing we can do is we can get
rid of these zeros because every time we
do this in the middle we're going to
have an extra zero and on the left side
we're going to have two zeros then we
can go ahead and make these green lines
thinner because
we can just say that we don't really
need to draw them as a thick line we've
already spaced them away from the other
lines so we know that these lines which
although we draw them as thin lines we
know they really count for 10 then we
can go ahead and remove these zeros
because it will always be the case that
those zeros will be there we can group
up the numbers and we can just change
the colors back to black so this is the
original picture we have of how 12 times
13 equals 156 and now you know where it
comes from those first lines we draw are
actually ten lines and then when we have
the spacing we have individual one lines
and the reason we can get the digits
just by the vertical alignment is the
way we've spaced the lines works that
way so now you understand how
multiplying by line works the summary of
this is that when you multiply two whole
numbers that's the same as counting the
number of dots of intersection between
them for bigger numbers there are going
to be lots of dots to count and
multiplying by lines is a shorthand to
count hundreds or even thousands of dots
very quickly in two-digit numbers we
group lines of tens as a bundle and in
three-digit numbers or higher numbers we
keep bundling powers of ten and we end
up with the vertical alignment which
gives us the answers to our final number
I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can also
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on Twitter at pressure Locker or again
my ebooks at Amazon